in the previous session we understood
the concept of a unit imaginary number I
it is the square root of negative 1 if
we square it we get root of negative 1
times root of negative 1 which equals
negative 1 the square of the unit
imaginary number is negative 1 well let
us now try to work out more powers of I
what will be I cube then try it out I
cubed is I times I times I we can write
it as I squared multiplied by I now as I
squared is equal to negative 1 I cubed
is negative 1 multiplied by i or
negative I so the value of I cubed is
negative I you can now similarly work
out 4th power of I give it a try the 4th
power of I can be written as I squared
multiplied by I squared this is nothing
but negative 1 multiplied by negative 1
and we already know that negative 1
multiplied by negative 1 is 1
hence the 4th power of I is just 1 so I
squared is negative 1 I cubed is
negative I and 4th power of I is 1 can
you similarly work out further powers
like 5th 6th 7th and 8th powers of I try
it out and you will observe something
interesting and this is what we would
get
notice the psychical pattern in the
powers I negative 1 negative I 1 and
then again I negative 1 negative I and
then 1 this is one way in which we can
understand it first power second power
third power and fourth power
then repeat fifth power sixth power
seventh power and eighth power and this
will go on so what is I it is just a
unit imaginary number and is equal to
the square
root of negative one why do I keep
saying the word unit to understand that
let's look at an example
what will the square root of negative
nine be equal to if we try it out on an
on fancy calculator it would say that
the input is invalid that's because most
calculators are not programmed to use
imaginary numbers so how do we
understand the square root of negative 9
it can be written as square root of 9
times negative 1 right and we know a
property of exponents which says that
square root of a times B is equal to the
square root of a time's the square root
of B so this can be written as square
root of 9 times the square root of
negative 1 the square root of 9 is 3 and
square root of negative 1 is I so the
square root of negative 9 is 3 I this is
3 times I and this is also an imaginary
number but it's not a unit imaginary
number as it's 3 times I but the unit
number I is 1 times I and hence it's
called a unit imaginary number
basically any real number times I is an
imaginary number for instance this is
how we would write square root of
negative 121 over 49 we get 11 over 7
times I it's a real number times I so
numbers like 0.14 5i 16.25
I minus cube root of 7i are also
imaginary numbers an imaginary number is
simply B times I where B is a real
number and I is the imaginary number so
if tomorrow morning what if your dad
asks you are imaginary numbers real how
would you answer that question well it's
a tricky question you should tell him
that imaginary numbers are not real
numbers they cannot be plotted on a real
number line but they are real in the
sense that they exist in mathematics and
are used widely in various applications
what kind of applications we'll see that
next
[Music]
you